Wut gegen Glanz und Gloria Wut gegen die
britische Monarchie
verstrickt in jahrhundertelang
Sklavenhandel im British Empire die
Kolonialmacht verkauft Millionen
Menschen quer über die Ozeane auch im
Namen der Krone
manche im Commonwealth können den weißen
Monarchen und den royalen Pomp nicht
mehr sehen
es erinnert daran dass der zur Schau
getragene Reichtum auf dem Rücken
unserer Vorfahren entstanden ist
für das Unrecht soll sich Charles
entschuldigen Zahlen bisher aber
bedauert er nur ich kann meine tiefe
persönliche Trauer über das Leid so
vieler nicht beschreiben
seit dem Tod der Queen werden die Gegner
lauter
commonwealtländer wollen ihren Monarchen
loswerden
Australien ist ziemlich durch damit
dieser Monarch hat keine Beziehung zu
Australien
kann König Charles sein Reich
zusammenhalten
[Musik]
als Charles III gekrönt wird hängen die
Flaggen all seiner Königreiche an der
Paradestrecke in London denn Charles ist
nicht nur König der Briten sondern auch
in 14 weiteren Ländern des weltweiten
Commonwealth of Nations
so wie in Jamaika in der Karibik vor
fast 400 Jahren besetzen die Briten den
Inselstaat beginnen ein globales
Geschäft das die Welt verändert den
Handel mit Sklaven in Afrika auf Schiffe
gezwungen zur Arbeit auf karibischen
Zuckerrohrplantagen
auf dem krönungsmarkt in der Hauptstadt
kingsten fremdeln viele mit dem König
von Jamaika Charles den dritten was der
Ferne Monarch für sie tut das wissen sie
nicht der König wie übrig geblieben aus
der Kolonialherrschaft des British
Empire
das britische Königshaus komplett ab
lange Zeit haben sie uns was schlaft
Wiedergutmachung ist ein Muss
erst vor gut 60 Jahren gewährt die alte
Kolonialmacht Jamaika politische
Unabhängigkeit damals kann etwa die
Hälfte der Menschen nicht lesen oder
schreiben ganze Generationen von
Familien geprägt von Sklaven Geschichte
und sozialem Elend
die Abneigung gegen das britische
Königshaus sitzt tief
belly Jamaika ohne das Königshaus leben
kann ich denke das wäre besser denn ich
sehe ihren Zweck nicht
das Königshaus bitten würde ist dass Sie
uns helfen wir leiden hier ich bin 26
Jahre alt und meine Arbeit ist
Handkarren schieben dabei habe ich
Talent kann singen kann Rappen doch weil
ich kein Geld habe komme ich nicht
weiter
der lange Einfluss der britischen
Herrschaft wirkt nach in Jamaikas Alter
wie überall in Charles fernen
Königreichen ein General Gouverneur ist
Stellvertreter des Monarchen einige
Großgrundbesitzer haben heute viel Land
alle anderen wenig die Briten haben sich
zurückgezogen
das Vereinigte Königreich noch heute im
Zentrum des kommen wollen entstanden aus
dem einst so mächtigen britischen
Kolonialreich den British Empire ein
freiwilliger Zusammenschluss von 56
Ländern verteilt über die ganze Welt
darunter 15 Staaten in den Charles noch
immer König ist
er ist zugleich Oberhaupt des gesamten
Commonwealth das hat ihn gewählt als
Nachfolger seiner Mutter Queen Elizabeth
II
[Musik]
die Sonderstellung der Monarchie und ihr
Glanz beeindrucken nähren die Illusion
dass das Vereinigte Königreich auf
globaler Ebene herausragende macht hat
ob das unter Charles im Commonwealth
[Musik]
im März 2022 Militärmarsch in Jamaika
für royalen Besuch der zum PR-Desaster
wird Bilder vom Thronfolgerpaar in
imperialer Attitüde William und
Catherine unterwegs in dem Jeep der
schon die Queen in den 50er Jahren an
Untertanen vorbeischweben ließ
jetzt wird es wie aus der Zeit gefallen
schwarze Kinder hinter Zäunen die Bilder
von der Reise im Auftrag ihrer Meister
der Königin wie ein unfreiwilliges
erinnern an die Sklaven Vergangenheit
sich dafür zu entschuldigen der Druck
auf die royale Familie wächst doch
Thronfolger und König Bedauern stets nur
werden nie deutlich sie sind zu
Neutralität verpflichtet ein
Entschuldigung wäre ein politischer Akt
und damit Sache der britischen Regierung
ich möchte meinen tiefen Kummer zum
Ausdruck bringen Sklaverei war
abscheulich und hätte niemals geschehen
dürfen
die Zurückhaltung des Prinzen macht die
jamaikanischen Monarchie Gegner immer
wütender unter den Demonstranten sind
vor eineinhalb Jahren auch die
Aktivistin Stacy and Shin und ihre
Tochter die Wut auf ihren Plakaten gegen
die Weißen Royals brennt
sie sollten nicht als Führer dieses
Landes willkommen geheißen werden als
Repräsentanten der Staatsspitze wer sind
diese beiden Jungen weißen Leute warum
sind Sie hier das wir vor ihnen Knicksen
uns verbeugen und Knien als wären sie
Götter
jetzt besuchen wir die Anti Monarchie
Aktivistin wieder in der jamaikanischen
Provinz sie bewirtschaftet hier eine
Farm auf der alle gleichberechtigt
arbeiten das ist ihr wichtig denn die
brutale Vergangenheit auf den Plantagen
ist ihr quälendes Thema
Jahrhunderte lang verbrauchte und
vernichtete solche Arbeit Menschen und
machte andere Reich die weiße
Oberschicht war die mit dem guten Leben
wenn ich 300 Jahre lang für dich
gearbeitet hätte und du nimmst das ganze
Geld das ich verdient habe und
investierst es um Infrastruktur zu
schaffen etwa in dein Haus oder in
Wasserleitungen sollte es nicht okay
sein für dich mir was zurückzugeben das
Geld dass du mir so lange gestohlen hast
du musst es zurückgeben und dann müssen
wir über Zinsen reden es geht nicht nur
um das was du einfach so genommen hast
sondern um das was du erreichen konntest
durch mich und meine Nachfahren
weil England profitierte müssen
Reparationszahlungen sein während
endlich gerecht sagt Stacy an noch immer
einen König als Symbol als dessen
Übersicht zu haben unmöglich in Jamaika
von heute
ins Royale Zentrum des Commonwealth die
britische Hauptstadt London
[Musik]
im Stadtteil Brixton Nachbarschaften mit
karibischen und afrikanischen London an
hier lebt auch der Filmregisseur John
Bauer er gehört zu einer alten
britischen Familie die heute in der
ganzen Welt verstreut lebt was seine
Vorfahren sieben Generationen vor ihm
während der britischen Kolonialzeit
eigentlich taten das fragt sich John
Dauer schon vor Jahren
irgendwann gibt er den alten
Familiennamen travellian ein in eine
öffentliche Datensammlung das
Verzeichnis britischer Sklavenbesitzer
dann der Schock
Sex Mitglieder der Familie die zusammen
1.000 und vier Sklaven besaßen erhielten
sechs Anwesen mit Ländereien in Grenada
sie wurden nach dem Verbot der Sklaverei
von England entschädigt mit 27.000 Pfund
das war der Beginn einer neuen Ära in
meinem Leben es hat mein Leben verändert
denn dadurch wurde mir klar dass sich
unsere Familie in nichts von all den
familienunterschied von denen ich dachte
dass wir anders sein
1834 wird britischen Geschäftsleuten der
Sklavenhandel verboten
46.000 von ihnen werden vom Staat
entschädigt auch die travellian-familie
nach heutigem Wert erhielten sie etwa
zwei bis drei Millionen Pfund
die Sklaven nichts mehr als ein Viertel
der gesamten Staatsausgaben von damals
zahlt die englische Regierung an
Sklavenhändler die größte staatliche
Finanzspritze vor der globalen
Bankenkrise 2008 ich fühle mich nicht
schuldig weil ich glaube dass man sich
nur für etwas schuldig fühlt dass man
getan hat also ich habe es nicht getan
ich besaß keine Sklaven wohl aber meine
Vorfahren die sich niemals entschuldigt
oder es uns auch nur gesagt haben
ich glaube ich schäme mich für Sie und
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich Ihnen
schon vergeben habe
viele Videokonferenzen und Debatten
später steht die Entscheidung der
Familie sie wollen etwas tun dass es
bisher nie gab sich bei der Bevölkerung
Grenadas entschuldigen
Anfang 2023 reisen Sie in dieses kleine
Karibik Reich von König Charles Grenada
nicht mal 150.000 Einwohner
John Bauer auf den Spuren der Sklaven
Vergangenheit durch die seine Familie zu
Hause in England reicher wurde die
karibischen Plantagen sind das lukrative
Zuckerland
mörderische Arbeit super heiß
sehr ernüchternd hier zu sein
er und einige Familienmitglieder
bekennen sich hier öffentlich sagen
Entschuldigung übergeben einen Brief und
knapp 127.000 Euro für einen lokalen
Fond
wir die Unterzeichner schreiben um uns
zu entschuldigen für das Handeln unserer
Vorfahren die ihre Vorfahren als Sklaven
hielten
dieser Brief wurde unterzeichnet von 104
Angehörigen der Teilhaber dieser
Plantagen
[Applaus]
wächst in Großbritannien ein Netzwerk
von Familien deren Vorfahren von Sklaven
Arbeit profitierten sie wollen sich
einsetzen für späte Gerechtigkeit
es macht mich glücklich zu wissen dass
ich euch vergeben kann
[Musik]
ein Vorbild sein und appelliert an die
royale Familie macht es wie wir
entschuldigt euch allerdings mit
größerer Geste und viel mehr Geld
Unterdrückung und weiße Schuld Anklagen
die Bewegung wächst seit einigen Jahren
weltweit seit den blacklives matter
Demonstrationen von 2020 nach der
Ermordung des schwarzen George Floyd in
den USA durch einen weißen Polizisten
vor allem auch in Großbritannien Sturm
auf Symbole von Unterdrückung in Bristol
holen Demonstranten die Statue von
Edward cohlsten vom Sockel als
Sklavenhändler im Dienst der Royal
African company verschiffte er Ende des
17 jahrhunderts Menschen aus Afrika in
die Karibik
[Applaus]
sten überträgt seine Anteile schließlich
an König William den dritten er und
seine Nachfolger profitieren von
Sklavenhandel ermächtig durch royalen
Erlass das sklavengeschäft und die
Handelsgüter aus den Kolonien treiben
Englands Aufstieg zur wirtschaftlichen
groß mach dem 18 Jahrhundert voran und
den immer noch sichtbaren Reichtum von
Banken Versicherungsagenturen Städten
eine der teuersten Meilen Londons die
Regent große Teile und die meisten ihre
Immobilien gehören zum Krones Date dem
Kronen besitzt eine Milliarden schwere
Holding deren Erlöse zum Teil an das
Königshaus gehen steuerfrei
zu dessen intransparenten
Besitzverhältnissen recherchiert die
Autoren Laura Clancy sie sagt über
soziale Ungleichheit könne man nicht
sprechen ohne die Monarchie in Frage zu
stellen das Königshaus nicht einfach
eine traditionelle Institution mit
langer Geschichte sondern durch die
Jahrhunderte und bis heute ein
machtvoller kapitalistischer Player
könnte uns das ist eines von vielen
Gebäuden des kronbesitzes in London fast
die ganze Region Street die Leute sehen
in der königlichen Familie das
zeremonielle nationale Identität oder
sie betrachten sie einfach als Royale
Familie und ihre Beziehungen aber sie
denken weniger an den Reichtum und die
Fülle der macht die man hat wenn man so
viel Land und Eigentum besitzt die
worlds aber funktionieren so wie andere
Unternehmen die viele Aristokraten und
sind schwerreich
seit dem Thronwechsel verändert sich die
Stimmung die Queen schien vielen wohl zu
erhaben um sie hart anzugehen die
Attacken der Kritiker gegen Charles
fallen schärfer aus wir müssen die
Monarchie loswerden bei der Aufzeichnung
eines Podcasts von
Politikwissenschaftlern in einer
Londoner Bar ist auch Laura Clancy dabei
als Expertin für royalen Reichtum
Monarchie Kritik für die Podcast da eins
der drängenden Themen der Zeit es kommt
jetzt vieles zusammen um die große Frage
zu stellen
und die Frage ist wird Charles der
letzte sein und wenn er es nicht ist
werden sie sich nicht beeilen müssen mit
der Krönung von
Williams auf ihren Unmut zahlen die
Risiken Kosten für Royale große
Ereignisse ein Charles Krönung
geschätzte 113 Millionen Euro und die
Beerdigungsfeiern für die Queen 186
Millionen Euro aus Steuergeldern was
eigentlich wäre wenn Großbritannien
nicht länger ein Königreich bliebe
stattdessen eine Republik würde eine
offene Frage ohne Antworten
das mangelt an Wissen über die
Alternativen es gibt keinerlei
Aufklärung dazu es wird nicht darüber
gesprochen es gibt keine schlüssige
antimonarchie-plattform im Vereinigten
Königreich keine einheitliche Position
einer der Mainstream Parteien
Protest gegen den pompt treibt am
Krönungstag die monarchiegegner auf die
Straßen Londons
nicht mein König ist ihr Schlachthof
sie fordern eine Republik und vorher all
dies
schaffen gestohlene Kulturgüter
zurückgeben anerkennen das Reichtum und
Macht aus der Zeit des Sklaverei stammen
Reparationen
Schulden erlassen für Länder die von der
Monarchie und Großbritannien zerstört
worden sind
mit all den echten Problemen die wir in
diesem Land haben scheint es falsch zu
sein dass wir hunderte Millionen Pfund
verschwinden um diese reichen
Aristokraten zu finanzieren
vor allem die Jungen sind dagegen bei
solchen Gelegenheiten sind die Gegner
laut aber noch immer eine Minderheit in
Großbritannien
im weit entfernten Commonwealth Land
Australien läuft am Krönungstag die
heilige Zeremonie zur besten abendlichen
Sendezeit
Australiens Monarchie Bündnis ist im
Castle Ray Hotel in Sydney versammelt um
zu feiern
Sushi wird angereicht das Haus wird
dennoch mit dem Charme der alten Welt
Charles ist auch König von Australien
besser kann es hier heute gar nicht
werden
sie mögen den glamourialer Traditionen
und das Gefühl Teil zu sein von etwas
scheinbar bedeutendem etwas Großem
ich bin ein australischer Bürger der
König von Australien hat eine wichtige
Position und dies ist seine Krönung
deshalb ist es wichtig für mich
ich mag die Tradition aber auch die
Verbindung die wir mit Großbritannien
haben aber ich finde es ist auch okay
wenn Leute anderer Meinung sind
ob Australien weiter ein Königreich sein
will eine solche Volksbefragung haben
die Monarchisten 1999 gewonnen es sind
vor allem die älteren die finden schaden
kann so ein König nicht an die britische
Monarchie sind Sie hier einfach gewöhnt
der wird Flint ist eine Größe im Lager
der australischen Monarchisten er hatte
maßgeblich dazu beigetragen dass ich
eine knappe Mehrheit beim Referendum für
die Monarchie aussprach die wird noch
lange halten glaubt
konnte ich bin zuversichtlich dass
Charles regieren wird und dann
vermutlich William und dann George der
siebte weil es dem australischen Volk
keine Probleme oder Schwierigkeiten
bereitet
Gefühl es kostet die Australien nicht
einmal was wir bezahlen die königliche
Familie nicht
konstitutionelle Monarchie wie in
Großbritannien die nicht ganz umsonst
ist auch australisches Steuergeld fließt
in das Amt eines general Gouverneurs der
den König in jedem seiner reiche
vertritt
für seine Familie interessieren sich
viele hier auch deshalb weil sie
promi-geschichten mögen das prägt die
Sicht vieler junge Australier auf
Monarchie
auf dem Uni Campus in Sydney ist gerade
Abschlussfeier Aufbruch die junge
Generation kann der Bedeutung von
Monarchie auch einer Krönung nichts mehr
abgewinnen und macht keinen Hehl aus
ihrem Desinteresse König einfach egal
es interessant es ist interessant ist in
den Nachrichten zu hören aber es
betrifft uns nicht so sehr wie die
Briten
einerseits muss man über Geschichte
Nachdenken aber auch über
gesellschaftlichen Fortschritt ich frage
mich spielt Monarchie Moment wirklich
eine Rolle nicht wirklich
die Forschungsgebiete von Professor
Cindy mcury British Empire und
englisches Königshaus sie gilt als die
top-expertin in Australien und kann
sagen warum die meisten der Studierenden
keine Emotionen hegen für die
monarchiest es liegt nicht nur am Alter
auch am Hintergrund viele Australier
sind mittlerweile asiatischer Abstammung
nicht europäisch und für sie gibt es
keine echte Verbindung zu Großbritannien
keine natürlichen Grund warum ein
britischer Monarch unser Staatsoberhaupt
sein sollte
für ein gewähltes australisches
Staatsoberhaupt kämpfen seit mehr als 30
Jahren Australiens Republikaner sind
gegen die Monarchie der Promi an der
Republikaner Spitze ist ein ehemaliger
Fußballnationalspieler
der fragt sich bei einem Bier am Tag
nach Charles Krönung was ein Schwur auf
den König eigentlich soll hier in Down
Under
[Musik]
als Charles gesagt hat jeder Australier
soll während der Krönungszeremonie
aufstehen und die Gefolgschaft laut
ausrufen
Schwachsinn auf keinen Fall
ich hätte gerne das alle mal die Hand
heben die letzte Nacht so einen Schuhe
geleistet haben
keine Hand geht hoch keiner hat den Eid
auf den König geleistet für Sie ein
älterer Mann von weit weg wenn ich einen
74-Jährigen Mann mit einer Juwelen
besetzten Krone in einer goldenen
Kutsche sitzen sehe auf einem goldenen
Thron vor dem Leute Knien dann ist das
letzte was ich denke das ist Australien
[Applaus]
zeitgemäß zu weiß zu wenig divers
dieser Mann wird in den nächsten 90
Jahren von zwei weiteren Männern
abgelöst werden allein angesichts von
Gleichberechtigung an die Australien
glaubt das sind wir nicht mehr
Republik werden das versuchen noch mehr
Königreiche auch Jamaika
der karibikstab plant ein Referendum
schon für 2024 die Monarchie macht sich
auf wegzukommen von der Krone
[Musik]
möglichst viele Jamaikaner mitreden zu
lassen über eine kommende Republik dafür
arbeitet Rosalie Hamilton und für die
eine Botschaft see you sorry
entschuldige Dich in jamaikanischem
Dialekt dass die Kolonialherrschaft in
Jahrhunderten Ressourcen Kultur und
würde aus dem Land zog das soll der
Monarch jetzt zu spüren kriegen
das Fehlen einer Entschuldigung fehlende
Wiedergutmachung und fehlende Rückgabe
von Artefakten der indigenen Bevölkerung
die im British Museum liegen
wenn diese Probleme nicht angegangen
werden steigern sich Wünsche immer mehr
der Monarchie den Rücken zu kehren
die Regierung hat bereits ein Komitee
eingesetzt dass eine Verfassung für die
Republik vorbereitet
die meisten der Netzwerker hier sind
aufgewachsen mit der Abneigung gegen die
weiße Monarchie auch annaise
ich erinnere mich als die Queen
gestorben war mein Vater meinte oh also
haben wir jetzt einen König großartige
Nachricht er war so sarkastisch und
meinte vielleicht werden wir sie ja
jetzt endlich los
barbados ist schon weiter hier geht eins
der englischen Königreiche in der
Karibik unter sie holen die königliche
Standarte ein haben 2021 die Monarchie
abgeschafft und die Republik ausgerufen
ist die erste Präsidentin der neuen
Republik Charles kommt zu diesem
feierlichen Anlass extra angereist um
Barbados zu sagen
kein König mehr dabei hatte das Land
stets als little England gegolten und
war auch von den Briten kolonisiert und
seine Einwohner versklavt worden ein
düsteres Vermächtnis
seit dem dunkelsten Tagen unserer
Vergangenheit und der entsetzlichen
Gräueltat des Sklaverei die unsere
Geschichte für immer prägt haben die
Menschen diese Insel mit
außergewöhnlicher Tapferkeit ihren Weg
geebnet
wie üblich royales Bedauern keine
Entschuldigung doch beides ist fest
entschlossen gute Beziehungen zu den
Briten zu pflegen und mit neuer
Staatsform im Commonwealth zu bleiben
sehr wichtig zu zeigen dass er nicht nur
König der Bürger im Vereinigten
Königreich ist sondern dass er ein
globaler Monarch ist es macht dieses
große Prestige aus die anderen 14
Königreiche im Commonwealth zu haben
sollte Charles nur der König von
Großbritannien bleiben könnte dies
wiederum Teile bundesvereinigten
Königreichs ermutigen ebenfalls die
Unabhängigkeit und den Status als
Republik anzustreben das wäre ein
enormer Prestigeverlust für die
britische Monarchie
als Spitze des Commonwealth muss der
König umso mehr globale softpower
entfalten damit die Macht des weltweiten
Staatenbundes wirkt und Englisch als
gemeinsame Weltsprache die Beziehung der
Länder festigt und natürlich die zur
Zentrale in Großbritannien so soll der
britische Mittelpunkt weiter Sogwirkung
haben in der Welt
Ruanda in Ostafrika ist im Commonwealth
erst 2009 beigetreten und hält derzeit
den Vorsitz
dabei war Ruanda nie britische Kolonie
sondern eine von Deutschland und Belgien
von seinen francophonen Traditionen
rückte das autokratisch regierte Ruanda
immer weiter ab und wendet sich
schließlich dem englischsprachigen
Kosmos zu dem Commonwealth Ruanda will
Teil haben am Versprechen von
wirtschaftlichem Nutzen und der
Annäherung an westliche Werte bei den
Studierenden an kikalis Universitäten
ist das gleichbedeutend mit Zukunft mit
Aufbruch und Augenhöhe die jungen machen
das Commonwealth aus 60% seiner Bürger
sind unter 29
das ist eine Chance für Ruanda zum
Commonwealth zu gehören ruanda ist ein
sich entwickelndes Land also haben wir
Möglichkeiten überall in der Welt und in
anderen kommen wills Staaten
öffnet das ganze Land zur Welt das setzt
unser Land Ruanda auf die Weltkarte als
sein Land das Englisch spricht
Ruandas Beitritt ist kein Einzelfall
auch autoritäre Staaten wie Togo und
Gabun erhoffen sich als neue Mitglieder
wirtschaftlichen und gesellschaftlichen
Nutzen vom englischsprachigen
Freundeskreis
der Vertreter der britischen Regierung
hat den Ruandas Hauptstadt Kigali seinen
Sitz es gibt ein Fest zur Krönung dass
das Commonwealth so zieht werden sie
hier so dass die Briten ihren Ruf längst
überwunden hätten imperiale groß macht
sein zu wollen
ich denke dass das Commonwealth eine
wirklich zukunftsorientierte Institution
ist auch wenn es aus der Geschichte
stammt aus der Kolonialzeit das Länder
wie Ruanda Gabun und Togo beitreten ganz
ohne historische Beziehungen zum
Vereinigten Königreich zeigt dass es für
etwas anderes steht für gemeinsame Werte
Demokratie Freiheit für den Ausbau von
Handel von kulturellen Verbindungen für
Bildung und ich denke dass seine
Majestät als Oberhaupt des Commonwealth
diese Themen wirklich vorantreiben wird
im Juni 2022 reist Charles nach Ruanda
da ist er noch nicht König aber Kopf des
Commons dessen Regierungsspitzen treffen
sich alle zwei Jahre sonst stets in
früheren Kolonien nun Ruanda
gegenseitiger Unterstützung versichert
man sich dann auch Großbritannien will
etwas vom Commonwealth Partner Ruanda
der Regierung hat mit dem afrikanischen
Staat einen politischen Plan gemacht das
brexit-land will in Zukunft Flüchtlinge
hierher abschieben dies zu Hause nicht
duldet die Unterkünfte bauen sie längst
für Millionen Pfund die Großbritannien
schon nach Afrika überwiesen hat ein
hoch umstritten
[Musik]
als woanders Staatsballett in Londons
Westminster Abbey tanzt feiern sie
Commonwealth day wie jedes Jahr gute
Tradition fortgeführt vom Monarchen der
im Gegensatz zur Queen hier seine
Botschaft höchstpersönlich verließ und
neue Berechtigung beschwört für ein
langlebiges Commonwealth of Nations
die unzähligen Verbindungen zwischen
unseren Nationen haben uns erhalten und
bereichert in mehr als sieben
Jahrzehnten
über viele weitere wird uns unser
Bekenntnis zufrieden Fortschritt und
Chancen tragen
das Zentrum bleiben das dürfte sich nur
halten lassen wenn sich die Monarchie
den blinden Flecken ihres kolonialen
Vermächtnisses stellt die
palastverwaltung gibt jetzt auch Geld um
eine Studie zu finanzieren besser
erforschen wofür die Krone während der
Kolonialzeit verantwortlich war
auf solcher Suche sind längst andere
Erben des Empire
wir sehen unsere Geschichte als die
eines Landes das verdient was es
bekommen hat dass wir glaubten die Welt
im Sinne des British Empire dominieren
zu können allein durch unseren
Einfallsreichtum und unsere
intellektuelle Brillanz
um ehrlich zu sein vieles davon wurde
durch die Religion unterstützt durch den
König und die royale Familie
dass wir es wie angeborenes Recht in
anspruchnahmen einfach einen Großteil
der Welt zu beherrschen dieser seltsame
Glaube hat uns durch ein paar
Jahrhunderte begleitet das zeigt dass
wir überzeugt waren das Recht zu haben
andere zu dominieren
und das wird meiner Meinung nach jetzt
immer mehr in Frage gestellt
der Druck auf Charles wird nicht mehr
schwinden in seiner Regierungszeit mit
all Ihren Fragen dem Unmut der Wut das
alles hat der König von England auch
geerbt so wie sein Königreich
[Musik]